[Música]
economía aquí en directo américa me
acompaña en el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge muy buenas noches vamos a comenzar
hablando de las declaraciones de
christine lagard sobre los tipos de
interés en europa que no cambiaban desde
hacía muchos años la funcionaria dice
que subirán los tipos de interés en
julio y septiembre precisamente para
controlar un mal global que es la
inflación la gare dijo que está
comprometida con actuar frente al
renovado riesgo de fragmentación también
de la eurozona para este año el banco
central europeo revisó a la baja las
previsiones de crecimiento económico el
emisor ahí tiene previsto subir los
tipos por primera vez en más de una
década el próximo mes uniéndose al resto
de bancos centrales de todo el mundo en
la subida del costo de los préstamos los
analistas esperan en julio una subida de
un cuarto de puntos mientras que el
siguiente movimiento será en septiembre
podría ser del doble de esa magnitud el
tipo de interés es actualmente del -0 5%
y es negativo desde 2014 escuchamos que
decía la funcionaria
aquí y si esperamos aplicar un nuevo
aumento de los tipos en septiembre cuya
calibración dependerá de los datos a
mediano plazo y podría ser más elevado
si las previsiones de inflación
persisten o se deteriora
woods stent anticipamos que la senda de
subidas de tipos continuará de manera
gradual en base a nuestros compromisos
del objetivo del 2% en la base por la
que ajustamos nuestra política monetaria
dependerá de los datos que lleguen y
como esperamos que la inflación se
desarrolle a mediano plazo
en the million trump
hablemos ahora del reino unido- este
país se alista para la mayor huelga de
trenes en tres décadas está a la vuelta
de la esquina ya bueno todo esto tras el
fracaso de las negociaciones con la
empresa en el contexto de una alta
inflación unos 40.000 limpiadores
señaladores trabajadores de
mantenimiento y personal de estación
anunciaron que se van de huelga durante
tres días durante esta semana reclamando
sobre todo mejores salarios y seguridad
laboral la huelga que es a nivel
nacional afectaría también los servicios
de metro de londres los sindicalistas
dijeron que las propuestas de los
empresarios son inaceptables mientras el
gobierno aseguró que la huelga traerá
sufrimiento y caos a millones de
usuarios de concretarse de santiago
sería la mayor huelga desde
'jorge pasamos del reino unido- a
colombia seguimos analizando el futuro
económico de este país después de la
elección de gustavo petro como nuevo
presidente de ese país suramericano
bueno petro propone grandes reformas en
términos económicos a partir del 7 de
agosto que será cuando tome posesión
entre las mayores propuestas de petros
están que empezará a desmontar la
industria de hydro carburos el
presidente electo de colombia pidió a
los países de américa latina que se unan
para hablar con eeuu y sentar las bases
de una transición energética ante los
estragos que ha causado el cambio
climático petro buscará también atender
una emergencia alimentaria que varios
organismos internacionales ya alertan al
decretar lo podría comprar cosechas a
campesinos y a pequeños y medianos
productores agrarios asimismo abogó por
una reforma agraria subiendo impuestos a
la tenencia de tierras sin usarse más de
la mitad de tierras de colombia el 52%
está en manos apenas del 1 5% de la
población según el centro de memoria
histórica
petro también ha dicho que cobrará más
impuestos a las 4.000 personas más ricas
de colombia y estas personas tendrían
una nueva obligación legal sobre sus
activos improductivos y respecto al
sistema de pensiones dijo que buscará
unificar el sistema público y privado
sin afectar la edad de jubilación
pasamos a chile' allí el dólar marcó un
máximo histórico por segundo día en este
país esto se debe a la caída de los
precios internacionales del cobre la
moneda estadounidense se cotizó en 881 9
y 884 10 vendedor según los operadores
locales y se robusteció un 0.86 respecto
a la jornada anterior el alza del dólar
en ese país se produce por la caída del
valor de las materias primas que en
chile afecto por el descenso del cobre
del que es principal productor mundial
la caída del metal coincidió también con
el aumento de las tasas de intereses de
los principales bancos centrales
incluidas la reserva federal de eeuu que
buscan controlar la inflación la minería
que representa ahí cerca del 10 por
ciento del producto interno bruto
nacional está jugando un papel
fundamental en la recuperación económica
tras la pandemia del coronavirus pasemos
ahora a los indicadores como las faldas
principales bolsas en las jornadas te
debo volver porque hoy no operaron
debido a un festivo en eeuu mientras que
en europa las acciones subieron con
fuerza este lunes después de una fuerte
venta la semana pasada por los temores
de recesión en américa latina' la
petrolera estatal petrobras cerró con s
romperte tras una jornada de gran
volatilidad por la renuncia de su
presidente e impulso a la bolsa de sao
paulo cuyo índice ibovespa avanzó 0,03
colombia también estuvo sin operación
también por ser festivo en este país
muchas gracias jorge por esta
actualización nosotros a continuación
les presentamos el debate aquí en
directo américa
[Música]